welcome to Haris hobbies the channel
where we discussed the latest tech news
and delve into newest tech products
today we're taking a look at the top six
things that you should consider before
buying a rise in CPU in mid 2018 but
before we delve into that make sure to
hit that subscribe button if you guys
like to stay updated with the latest
tech news related to gaming and PCs so
starting off with number one you have to
remember that this is basically what
Intel would call a talk upgrade and not
the ticke upgrade so what to talk
upgrades it's basically the same CPU as
the year before with some small
improvements like clock speed and things
like that as you guys can see rise and
second generation really only offers
more clock speed than rising first
generation and the thing is is that the
rise in third generation that is coming
out next year is going to be the big
upgrade that brings a lot more
performance rise and third generation is
going to be on a seven nanometer process
and the rise in seventh series for the
third generation of Rison may even have
12 or 16 cores on top of this we may see
clock speeds as high as 5 gigahertz for
some of the CPUs as a result if you can
wait till the next generation of rising
cpus come out then that may be the wiser
decision because for the same price here
we get a lot more performance and this
is just really a small upgrade over
first generation rise and while the
third generation is going to be a huge
upgrade so just make sure to keep in
mind the second generation of Rison is
just a small upgrade and if the
regeneration of rise is going to big
upgrade and it's coming out next year
before you purchase your rise in second
generation or first generation CPU right
now and moving on to number two you have
to remember that Rison is still really
only good if you're looking for a really
good value if you want the best
performance available then Intel still
has that crown for gaming and
productivity as for gaming if you want
the best gaming performance available on
the mainstream platform and your best
bet would probably be the Intel i7 8700
K and if you want the best productivity
performance and you would probably want
to wait for the new coffee like CPU
that's coming out later this year that's
going to have eight cores and 16 threads
from Intel as it is clear Anto still has
the best performing CPUs but AMD
definitely still has a lot more value to
provide
in tow because of the pricing situation
so just make sure keep in mind that if
you're looking for the best performance
available and your best bet is still in
tow and not rising however if you are
looking for the best performance
available for every single dollar that
you spend then rise nough still your
best bet so make sure to keep in mind
that you are not getting the best
performance available when buying an AMD
CPU moving on to number three make sure
that you make your purchase decision
based on what you're going to be using
PC for for example if you're mostly
going to be doing productivity related
apps like video editing and modeling and
you want to rise in CPU then yes you
should go with the rise and seven series
however if you're mostly just going to
be doing gaming and maybe some light
streaming then really you only just need
a rise in five CPU so make sure to keep
in mind that rising 5 is all you really
need for gaming and rising 7 is really
meant for productivity and the gaming
performance difference between the rise
and 7 and rise and pipe series is really
quite minimal so make sure to really
think about what you're going to be
using your PC for so you can get the
best tip you that will suit you and your
needs and branching off this one as for
number 4 make sure you were not
overspending when you're buying your
rise at CPU and motherboard for example
most of you guys really only need to
rise into 5 CPU because of what you guys
to do with your PC so there's really no
reason for you guys to buy the rise in 7
CPU instead what you guys should do is
buy a rise in 5 CPU and use the money
that you save and get a better GPU if
possible because that will really
improve your gaming experience much more
than the rise of 7 CPU would also unless
you were going for an extreme build
there's really no reason for you to get
at X 370 or X 470 motherboard but B to
be 50 or B 450 motherboard is really all
everyone needs finally don't get a CPU
cooler because the stock coolers at AMD
offers are already really good and from
a performance standpoint they perform
just as well as most other CPU coolers
and because of that there are a lot of
other places that you can spend your
money yet before getting another CPU
cooler so overall just get it Rison 5
CPU with ABI 450 or be 350 motherboard
and use a stock cooler because that
already performs really well and you can
use that money for other place in your
computer which were much more
significantly improve your performance
so really just make sure you're not
overspending on products that really
won't give you a performance next up on
to number five make sure that you were
getting right and supported Graham
nowadays RAM compatibility with rising
has gotten a lot better but even now
make sure to do your research and find
out whether your RAM can actually hit
its full speed with your eyes and CPU
also don't skimp out and get twenty one
thirty three or twenty four hundred
megahertz Ram I know that Ram is pretty
expensive right now however at that
point a couple of dollars really won't
hurt and three thousand or thirty two
hundred microgram just performs so much
better with Rison so it really is worth
a little bit of extra money RAM speed
does significantly affect your
performance so make sure you were
getting high-speed Ram
so overall make sure you are getting RAM
that is supported by Rison and make sure
you're getting the high speeds that you
can afford because it really does make a
big difference
lastly for number six make sure that you
remember that Rison is still a new
platform and it has only been out for a
little over a year now and as a result
there are still some bugs here and there
and support Verizon is not as good as
Intel Intel CPUs have been out for a
much longer time and as a result
applications have had a longer time to
adapt to the rise in CPUs have only been
out for a little more than a year and as
a result not all applications have
adapted to it
so overall make sure to remember that
you may not get all the performance out
of your rising CPU right off the bat and
it may take some time before all the
apps that you use are fully supported by
Rison but that's pretty much all I have
for you guys this time did I miss
something really crucial that you need
to consider before buying a rising CPU
make sure to comment that down below
because I do it all my comments and I'm
curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like this video then make sure
drop a like it hit that subscribe button
if you guys like to see more videos just
like this one but until next time bye